the 2017 Cinco cup was so exciting
magnus carlsen was back in the mix and
the opening festivities were also a
quite exciting absolutely we had the
fashion the show we had the competition
pinned that we all were involved in we
both were involved in in Christianity
couple of other grandmasters advising
these fashion designers on trying to
create HS uniform and I was quite proud
of the results on my side I might say
yes that's right you won with your
designer are dry and that was a melange
of the bishop and the rook showing the
power of the Queen absolutely the
combination of the forces being better
to being together than just being alone
and it was the the clash of these
diverse forces that created this new
design so it was quite fun to be a part
of that and I think it was the most
elegant of all the opening ceremonies
we've ever done I mean you had all these
fashion models going around and what
more could you want then fashion and
chess it's awesome it was really fun I
worked with Ananias designer Emily Anne
it was all about creating this chess
uniform and I think it's significant
that some of the players namely at
Magnus Carlsen that actually worked in
fashion before so these these players
very elegant Maxine Bachelor to grab
Levon Aronian I mean the top players in
the world know how to dress Maurice it's
not just you well I an itch Gary you
could mention as well who's always a
stylist a stylish guy I think it's
important we have to present chess in
this way that says we're not just about
playing moves but we also may set trends
and so it was quite cool to have that
happen and right after that it was time
for some fashionable chess and that was
a very exciting beginning to that event
that's right so tell us a little bit
about this event it was extremely
competitive probably the most
competitive Singh field Cup in a lot of
ways without question it was absolutely
the most competitive
first of all Magnus was not playing well
he had not won a super tournament since
2016 in Bavaro okay yes he did defend
his title against Carr yakun but after
that you know Magnus wants to win
everything that he plays in and he
didn't win the grand classic Aronian was
playing extraordinarily well be
Magnus a couple of vicious clubbing in
fact we had Wesley who had this meteoric
rise after winning the same field cup
the year before and so many events that
he wanted when the gold medal at the
Olympiad
with the team also on his individual
board he also won London he also won
Tata Steel he won the US Championship so
he had slowed down a little bit by the
time the same field club came around but
still people were trying to catch their
breath from how much he was victorious
and so you had all these players in the
mix and you wouldn't a suspected the boy
who actually finally won but it just
showed how competitive chess had become
right at that moment and we were
expecting to see great things one of the
most memorable things for me in that
tournament was this battle royale
between Magnus Carlsen and Maxine bye
Cheryl I got literally a game that you
couldn't keep your eyes off of it was a
tremendous game and Maxime had won his
first game to go to plus 1 and then
Magnus wins his next game the next round
to go to plus one as well
so when they meet it's it's Magnus it's
it's Maxime and it's Fabi all tied for
first and this battle was insane I
remember we were calling it it was up
and down and it looked like Magnus was
really getting the better of Maxime and
Mike seemed showed his typical tricky
style you think you have them you think
you've grabbed them and it's like an eel
he's so slippery comes up with the idea
after idea and just when Magnus thought
okay now I have him Magnus plays two
howler of rook moves the first one
wasn't so bad but the second one simply
causes major damage to his position and
he gets wiped off the board in a
thriller yeah an incredibly complicated
endgame and it's funny because you know
when you think about Magnus I think
about these rivalries and of course I
think about Fabiano Carolina when it
comes to classical chess there well a
championship match I'm being tied and
going into rapid which by the way it did
first cardiac and as well but when I
think about the rivalry of blitz chess
you think of a maxium and Magnus
absolutely and that may have been the
early beginning because at the point at
that point Maxime hadn't done anything
special you don't want a super
tournament he was clearly an excellent
player
he'd won the lesser tournaments and he'd
risen to these rarefied heights but it
was this event that started showing it
and in this this particular round that
knocked Magnus down a notch but like a
champ
Magnus bounced back the very next round
and won and show that look just because
I lose it doesn't mean I'm going to stay
down but he is this point always chasing
mvl also in that round 5 the quiet one
the tiger of madras anon beats Fabi
amazing game maybe the game of the
tournament the the fight of the
tournament was certainly MVL against
Cara Juana
but on on beginning Cara wanna with
beautiful Queen sacrifice I mean this
was something special that was
definitely the move of the tournament
maybe the move of the Sinquefield Cup I
mean Queen d4 I think everyone's heart
drops when they saw that heart dropped
everyone's heart exploded when they saw
that move because it was just so
beautiful and it was also accessible was
the kind of move that you might miss
even if you're a really strong player
because it's so surprising but even if
you're an amateur it captures our heart
Bobby didn't see it probably missing
himself if he had seen it coming he
certainly wouldn't have gone down this
line and Anand you know there's always
the calls for him to retire maybe he's
getting older it's the most ridiculous
thing you could imagine this great
champion who's once won everything and
won so many titles and he loves playing
chess
why would you say a word to him he
continues to marvel he continues to show
why he's one of the great legends of the
game and that game really showed it and
that put him also at +1 and then in a
couple of rounds he wins again and
suddenly he's at +2 and you see that
MBL's at +2 Magnus is busy floating
around there as well and Aronian comes
back into the mix also and he goes to +2
and car yakin wins after having lost him
lost earlier in the in the event to
Magnus he wins again and just before the
final round you have five players who
could win the tournament three of them
tied going into the last round now this
simply never happened before and we were
all three
old thinking what's gonna happen on the
last day we thought for sure it was
gonna be a tight break yeah I remember
being both thrilled but also a little
bit stressed because I there were some
strange tiebreaks if there were like
three people tied for first so I in my
heart I was like okay maybe somebody can
just win it
I love tiebreaks but it was such a
exciting last round and I have to say
the maximum game really left a big
impression on me
yes Maxime basically it was a situation
where if you win you know you're in to
at least a tie-break and then you have
these two other players who if they win
then you're gonna play against one or
both of them and Aronian goes down and
goes down against Magnus that's of
course Magnus had to deliver he had to
win and hope things worked out his way
and he showed what a great champion he
is I'm able to do that Vichy draws his
game quite quickly and tepidly and we
were surprised shocked that he did that
given that he needed to think about his
chances but I think he didn't want to
take any chances especially I believe he
had the black pieces in that last round
and then suddenly there's MVL and he
goes if I win
it's over and he plays just a beautiful
classical masterpiece against the pro
Miyaichi who was not playing well at all
that and that event ended up in last
place at the bottom of the tournament
table but this game when you have to
deliver this is the sign of a champion
and MVL did exactly that in this moment
that's right and I remember that night
on d5 it was really like something out
of my system yeah as his favorite buck
stunning knight on d5 and it ruled the
game well it's the kind of position
where you don't want to have when your
blackness Sicilian and both of us know
you never want to have to watch this
night dominating and he took it and he
opened up the game with it and then he
showed what kind of technique he had and
for maxing this was a great moment
because it was his first big event
Magnus was quite congratulatory as he
always is when people play Wow
he came in second you know so he he's
happy also that he is not at the bottom
of the tournament table or even third is
horrible for him to contemplate but he
was quite congratulatory about Maxime
and this was Mike seems real arrival to
say yes I
finally win these super tournaments
indeed Maxine was always up there in the
high rankings but in terms of actually
getting the W it seemed like it eluded
him and I have to say it was just
beautiful to see him win it a great
gentleman and somebody who just has such
a pure love for chess it was in
sportsmanship just wonderful
sportsmanship even though he'd come so
close to winning the grand chest or you
know he always really took it like a
champ and now he was the champ and to
make a big point as well this was now
the fifth consecutive different winner
of the Sinquefield Cup how does that
happen I mean it's just it the Ziegfeld
Cup continues to give us these
incredible nuggets to remember and to
its really marvel at by its specialness
it almost makes you wonder could it have
gotten any better in 2018